ciao ciao ciao c'est donc en Lorine qui
a été entièrement tourné ce documentaire
il était une fois dans l'Est réalisé par
Samuel bolendorf et my audig un film
vous venez de le voir qui accompagne des
salariés qui chaque jour vont travailler
au Luxembourg un voisin aux allures
d'Eldorado économique mais ce film en
dit également beaucoup sur la vie
post-industrielle aujourd'hui dans cette
région nous allons y revenir maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
de débadoc Samuel Bollendorf est avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes donc le
coréalisateur de ce film avec Medy Audi
vous êtes documentariste bien entendu
après vous être consacré un certain
temps au
photojournalisme au sein notamment de de
l'agence œil public qui malheureusement
fermé hein en 2010 c'est une agence
indépendante 5 ans de collaboration
aussi hein au quotidien Libération vous
êtes Franco luxembourgeois vous êtes né
à Paris mais votre père lui est luxemb
bourgeois on va bien sûr reparler de
votre film ce qu'il faut en tirer à
l'occasion de de notre échange et on va
le faire avec vous Isabelle roche
bienvenue vous êtes député horizon de la
Moselle de la 9e circonscription
englobant notamment tonville et le pays
des trois frontières on va y revenir
dans un instant avec une carte hein
puisquil y a pas que le Luxembourg
évidemment qui est frontalier avec la
Moselle et la meurt et Moselle et vous
êtes par ailleurs présidente de la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation de l'Assemblée nationale
et conseillère régionale du Grand estre
remmi lefève est enfin avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes politiste ou
politologue hein c'est au choix
professeur des universités en sciences
politiques à l'Université de Lille et
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule faut-il
désespéré de la gauche point
d'interrogation bien sûr la réponse est
à chercher aux éditions textuelles une
carte je vous l'avais promise pour
commencer bien entendu pour bien situé
où a été tourné votre film regardez sur
cette carte on voit la Lorine en bleu
avec la la la Moselle et la mortemoselle
et puis cette fameuse région des des
trois frontières là on est sur votre
circonscription Isabelle roche qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle cette région des Trois
Frontières il y a pas seulement le
Luxembourg il y a c'est aussi frontalier
avec deux autres pays c'est frontalier
avec l'Allemagne donc ma circonscription
est frontalière avec l'Allemagne et le
Luxembourg mais si on va un peu plus
loin si on remonte donc sur la frontière
c'est la frontière belge la frontière
belge c'est donc là que vous avez tourné
ce film il a été bien accueilli sur
place film tourn on le rappelle par un
franco luxembourgeois vous êtes pas du
coin vous hein vous avez été bien
accueilli avec ce documentaire alors je
suis pas du coin mais j'ai quand même
beaucoup traversé cette région dans mon
enfance et puis on a passé 2 ans sur le
terrain puisqu'on a travaillé dans le
cadre également d'une capitale
culturelle européenne à H suralz de
l'autre côté de la frontière et euh on a
pu tisser des relations très intenses et
de au long cours avec les protagonistes
du film 2 ans de travail hein c'est ce
que vous VZ nous dire he absolument et
et donc il ont tous été invités à la à
une avant-première au moment du
lancement de la capitale culturelle
européenne et de de l'exposition qui
avait lieu à h surlz et du film et il a
été oui oui il a été très bien accueilli
oui il y a des
personnages donc vous avez suivi le
parcours depuis la fin de ce film leur
situation on peut-être évolué par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire il y en a-t-il qui on
retrouvé du travail par exemple au
Luxembourg hein je pense à cette femme
qui qui cherchait du du travail de
l'autre côté de la frontière d'autres
peut-être qu'ils l'ont perdu ce travail
qu'ils avaient au Luxembourg depu depuis
la réalisation de ce film euh non il y a
Alexandra effectivement qui a fait ce
burnout qu'on voit qui a quitté la
banque et le et le Luxembourg qui a
finalement retrouvé du travail en France
et qui maintenant travaille dans une
agence bancaire à HES donc à côté de
chez elle bon est-ce que vous avez
retrouvé votre région globalement euh
ses habitants ses murs ou une partie de
ses murs dans ce film une toute toute
petite partie non j'avoue ne pas ne pas
M être retrouvé
pourquoi je enfin déjà c'est c'est un
documentaire qui commence dans le
brouillard sous la
pluie c'est pas alors qu'il faut il fait
toujours beau en Lorine il fait toujours
beau en Lorine donc en fait c'est ça
donne une tonalité de de quelque chose
quand même de finalement voilà on est
dans le brouillard on sait pas trop où
on va c'est c'est enfin moi j'ai
trouvais que c'était très pesant donc
c'est pas l'atmosphère en tout cas c'est
pas moi forcément la réalité de de ce
que je vis c'est la réalité d'une partie
de la population mais comme dans tout
dans on va dire dans toute région il y a
des des choses qui vont bien des choses
qui vont moins bien et là c'est vrai que
pour moi ça a été voilà je me suis dit
ça y est on montre encore la Lorine avec
ce
côté on a perdu l'industrie heureusement
qu'il y a le Luxembourg mais c'est très
difficile et on ne montre pas aussi tout
ce qui va bien et tout ce qui fait que
les on gagne des habitants qu'il y a des
gens qui ont envie de venir voilà j'ai
trouvé ça et heureusement heureusement
on va dire le les dernières images du
film les dernières images du film on
voit un peu de soleil je me suis waouh
ça y est il a fallu attendre les les
dernières images pour finalement avoir
quasi une note d'espoir avec euh avec ce
ce plan euh ensoleillé h alors je je
vais redonner la parole au au
réalisateurs je voulais d'abord savoir
ce que vous en avez pensé de ce film
réil feu qu'est-ce qui vous a qu'est-ce
que vous est venu à l'esprit en
regardant ce film sur cette situation
socioéconomique dans cette région avec
cette particularité effectivement du
travail frontalier dont on va reparler
avec le Luxembourg forcément moi j'ai
fait le rapport avec moi ma ma propre
situation géographique moi j'habite à à
lillele non loin de la Belgique et la
situation des transfrontaliers est quand
même assez différente c'est globalement
il y a pas beaucoup de flux de
population il y en a hein euh mais euh
il y a la Belgique n'est pas l'Eldorado
que représente le Luxembourg voilà donc
bon voilà ça ça ça c'est c'est la
première remarque la la deuxième
remarque moi ce que j'ai trouvé alors
c'est un film j'ai pas trouvé le film
lugubre mais j'ai trouvé très
mélancolique c'est un très beau film un
très beau documentaire mélancolique
alors moi je suis pas sûr que ça soit
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça prétend
donner une image générale de la région
je ne pense pas c'est c'est c'est une
image qui est centrée sur les
frontaliers c'est un certain type de
population hein il y a il y a 200000
frontaliers au Luxembourg qui
travaillent au Luxembourg il y en a
100000 qui viennent de la France là
clairement c'est un focus une focale qui
est porté sur des des frontaliers alors
don dont on ne sait parfois pas
grand-chose mais on sait en fait qu'ils
ont ils valorisent le travail qui
effectivement il y a cette attraction
pour le pouvoir d'achat du Luxembourg il
y a un côté familialiste aussi ils sont
très attachés à la famille il y a un
côté très individualiste aussi c'est des
milieux populaires mais qui ont accédé à
la propriété qui accèdent en fait à un
certain bien-être matériel mais en même
temps qui sont pas très épanouis non
plus forcément et je trouve qu'ils sont
un peu pris au piège finalement de de de
ce travail qui qui leur permet d'accéder
à une connaissance sociale un niveau
social mais où ne s retrouve ne se
retrouve pas complètement hein et je
trouve que ce qui est très beau dans
dans le documentaire c'est ce
tiraillement identitaire entre
finalement des gens qui ont voilà qui
ont accédé à un certain niveau de vie
par le Luxembourg mais qui en même temps
sont attaché à la France ont aussi des
des voilà des des conditions de vie qui
sont pas simples le le le temps passé en
la route l'intensité du travail et voilà
j'ai trouvé que c'était un beau portrait
alors moi je ne prétends pas connaître
très bien le territoire mais j'ai trouvé
que c'était une belle un bel éclairage
sur cette sur cette population alors
Samuel bolendorf là je pense que c'est
le moment de préciser ce qui étaaiit vos
intentions avec ce tournage pour
répondre peut-être à l'un et à l'autre
bah de toute façon nos intentions
c'était évidemment pas de de de faire un
un un film sur les plus beaux paysages
laurins et et et et l'idée n'est pas de
débattre de la météo laorine si ce n'est
que ce sont des gens qui se lèvent très
tôt parce que il y a une vraie question
de mobilité qui qui parfois se lève à à
5h du matin pour pouvoir embaucher à à
7h30 au au Luxembourg et donc
généralement quand on se lève tôt il
fait nuit et il y a de la brume souvent
même quand il va faire beau la journée
et il ne profite pas de la Lorine la
journée euh par contre effectivement
c'est cette euh ce travail de 40h de
l'autre côté de la de la frontière euh
et cette voilà cet asservissement quand
même à à la question du temps euh et de
la mobilité euh euh ce coût qu'il paye
c'est pour cet accomplissement matériel
effectivement de de classe populaire euh
qui peuvent en profiter le weekend et et
profiter de leur de leur voiture
décapotable effectivement quand il y a
un rayon de soleil donc c'est quand même
ce qu'on essayait de montrer dans dans
ce film même si effectivement on fait
vraiment un focus sur la question des
frontaliers mais ce qui nous intéressait
c'était vraiment effectivement ce ces
classes populaires qui évidemment ont
connu euh tout le
destin de la de la sidérurgie en Lorine
et du déclin quand même d'une grande
partie de ce qui faisait l'emploi et qui
aujourd'hui pour cela puisque la
question c'est les frontaliers
çaacomplissent grâce au Luxembourg
accèdent à à à effectivement un confort
matériel que leur
contemporain qui ne traversent pas la
frontière non'ont pas exactement de la
même façon mais effectivement c'est un
coup et on a essayé de le raconter au
travers de de ses intimités finalement
et et de ses destins effectivement de
gens qui en plus grâce au covid ou à
cause du covid ont fait plus de
télétravail et ont pris la mesure euh de
de combien ils ne connaissaient pas leur
famille parfois il y a des il y a des
des gens qui nous racontaient euh qu'
découvraient que leur filles avaient une
passion pour le cheval ou des choses
comme ça parce que finalement ils ils
ont été au contact de leur famille ils
ont pris la mesure de de du prix de de
cette mobilité pendulaire quoi je crois
qu'on a bien compris ce qui était vos
intentions avec ce film on va voir un
extrait je vous donne tout de suite la
parole juste après parce qu'évidemment
le thème central c'est c'est ce travail
frontalier et tout naturellement vous
avez demandé pourquoi mais pourquoi
allez-vous travailler au Luxembourg
voilà la
réponse autour de moi personne
travaillit au Luxembourg j'ai fait la la
connaissance d' ami qui lui travaillait
déjà dans une banque et du coup j'ai
donné mon CV comme ça et mois plus tard
je
bossais il y a y a aucun poste en France
que je pourrais faire où je toucherai la
même chose c'est pas possible avec mon
on va dire mon niveau de qualification
et tout ça c'est pas possible de trouver
des un revenu comme ça en France je suis
si on regarde les statistiques
françaises des des revenus médian moyen
machin je fais partie de on fait partie
de la poation des 10 % de Français qui
gagnent le plus quoi alors voilà il
gagne le doup de ce qu' pourrait gagner
en France avec la même qualification
hein si on a bien compris ce que nous
dit cette personne qui allait travailler
au Luxembourg dans sa voiture bon c'est
ça le Luxembourg l'eldoraldo
luxembourgeois ce qui attire plus de
100000 laurins je crois aujourd'hui tous
les jours aller travailler au Luxembourg
c'est ce fameux eldorado économique oui
en fait j'avais envie de réagir quand
même au propos qui ont juste avant qui
ont été tenus parce que quand je dis le
bulletin mutéo effectivement c'était pas
un bulletin mutéo que je faisais mais
c'était bien une analyse du film et vous
l'avez bien confirmé avec un côté très
sombre au départ et un parti prix
justement de montrer une certaine
réalité pour finalement terminer sur un
la décapotable et et le fait de pouvoir
en profiter donc ce que j'ai dit était
tout à fait en concordance en tout cas
le ressenti avec l'intention du film et
c'est pas exactement comme ça que moi je
perçois le territoire dans son ensemble
on est bien sur une petite petite partie
de de du du de la population et je c'est
la moiselle c'est plus d'un million
d'habitants donc je donc si on met la
meurt et Moselle on est on est quasiment
sur un un bassin de de vie enfin pour
Moselle et Meur et Moselle
d'7 700000 habitants là on a 100000
frontaliers donc on voit que c'est pas
toute la réalité d'un territoire je
crois que ça aussi c'est quand même très
important maintenant ceux qui sont dans
cette réalité la motivation profonde de
ces 100000 personnes
est la motivation salariale les
avantages que ça procure par rapport à
la France mais comme mais comme tout un
chacun j'ai lisais un article des échos
la semaine dernière qui disait qui
disait que la motivation des jeunes pour
aller bosser c'est le salaire aussi donc
même la génération Z on avait sur donc
on voit bien que une des motivations
principales pour les les gens pour aller
travailler c'est quand bien la question
du salaire donc oui une la la motivation
pour aller de l'autre côté de la
frontière elle est là elle est elle est
parce qu'il y a aussi de l'emploi mais
en tant que politique on s'attache aussi
à faire en sorte qu'il y ait maintenant
enfin et de de l'emploi sur sur la sur
la Lorine et on voit le taux de chômage
d'ailleurs on est dans les mêmes eau on
est dans les mêmes proportions que le
niveau national donc c aux alentours de
7 % aujour au alentour de 7 % oui bon je
pense que c'est et puis ça a permis
aussi d'attirer un certain nombre de
population ça permet de pouvoir
concevoir et de construire des filières
même de d'enseignement supérieur si je
prends mon territoire et thville c'est
comme ça qu'on crée un 4e département
d'ut c'est voilà c'est c'est tout c'est
tout cela aussi c'est pas uniquement ce
côté euh j'ai envie de dire enfin très
lourd et très noir euh et il est pas
très noir pour les personnes qu'on a vu
dans ce documentaire parce que un peuême
les voitures décapotabl les mais non
mais mais en
fait d' au la sele contte effectiv
lesrours jeis difficile et peut- des
conditions de travail sur place est ce
que laisse aussi entendre un peu ce film
parfois un
peu dégradant pour certains salariés qui
travailleraient sur place oui ben moi je
pense que ce que je sens dans votre
discours c'est aussi je pense que quand
on est élu de ce territoire ça doit pas
être facile d'avoir des des gens comme
ça qui sont frontalier parce que
concrètement il doit avoir des
convoitises il des inégalités c'est
c'est pas des des je pense que quand on
est quand on est élu et je moi je suis
pas élu je suis pas de ce territoire là
mais je sens que ça doit être une
question un peu sensible parce que
effectivement il y a aussi finalement
moi je le vois en tant que politistes
c'est des milieux populaires qui sortent
un peu de leur classe hein qui sont on
parle beaucoup de déclassement
aujourd'hui dans les milieux populaires
là on est dans une situation très
différente on est dans une situation où
effectivement les gens pas très
qualifiés ils peuvent voyager ils
peuvent aller à Center Park ils peuvent
avoir des des maisons individuelles et
puis je dirais même alors moi j'ai des
j'ai aussi des questions à poser c'est
que dans cette dans ce lotissement parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
passe dans le lotissement de lotissement
en fait de de ces 400 maisons qui ont
été construites par ce garçon là qui est
dont le père était aussi vender aussi
des maisons c'est que est-ce qu' est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi une forme de
séparatisme c'est est-ce qu' est-ce
qu'il se regroupe pas entre entre eux on
a l'impression qu'il y a une logique
d'entre soi et donc cet entre soi là
est-ce que c'est pas aussi une manière
bah de se protéger peut-être d'autres
d'habit qui n'ont pas les mêmes
facilités donc ils vivent un petit peu
dans une bulle on a l'impression de
d'une bulle en fait he d'une bulle
spatiotemporelle ils partent travailler
ils reviennent ils sont dans leur
lotissement ils se baladent dans leur
lotissement ils en sortent un peu avec
leur belle voiture il y a il y a ce ce
guitariste là qui qui dit qui qui part
en voyage parce que il a accès très
rapidement au voyage donc et il y a il y
a un rapport au territoire qui je trouve
assez étonnant voilà et c'est vrai qu'on
voit pas les autres alors on voit pas
ceux qui ne partent pas mais j'imagine
que la coexistence parfois avec on les
voit boire un verre hein devant des
bâtiments avec alors votre réponseà
après tout tout le monde enfin et dans
une famille tout le monde n'est pas
frontalier bien sûr dans dans des
couples même très souvent il y en a un
qui est frontalier l'autre qui n'est pas
qui cré des différences de classe ce
travail frontalier auquel vous êtes
confronté en tant que responsable
politique justement mais c'est euh c'est
un enfin vous le disiez c'est
effectivement un défi aussi de de savoir
comment on fait pour que le logement
soit accessible pour des fonctionnaires
qui vont qui qui œuvrent sur le
territoire pour qu'un enseignant puisse
se loger pour que voilà toute on va dire
tout un chacun puisse y avoir accès
parce que en effet ce
travail les personnes qui vont
travailler de l'autre côté ont un
pouvoir d'achat qui n'est pas le même
que ceux qui restent localisés en France
donc oui on a des prix de notamment dans
l'immobiliers qui euh qui sont tirés
vers le haut et c'est un réel défi pour
pour l'élus que je je suis donc à voir
comment on fait politiquement pour
trouver des solutions en effet pour
rendre c'est essentiellement le logement
accessible à tous maintenant av des
défis logistiques routiers par exemple
hein parce que il y a quelqu'un qui
prend une maison puis la gent immobilier
lui dire regardez vous allez même
pouvoir regarder les voir de de votre
terrasse vous verrez les embouteillages
qu'il y a pour aller travailler au
Luxembourg mais mais il y a aussi le le
défi de l'inclusion de tous dans la vie
citoyenne mais c'est pas propre au
fontalier parce que quand on quand on
s'élo de la frontière parce que plus on
s'éloigne de la frontière moins on a de
frontalier donc plus on a plus on a desj
envie dire de couple mixes ou voilà mais
on a les mêmes difficultés dans les dans
les villages dans les communes un peu
plus loin de la frontière de savoir
comment on fait en sorte que les
citoyens participent à la vie communale
donc c'est c'est peut-être
exacerbé plus on va vers la frontière et
encore je pense que c'est un problème de
société qui dépasse le fait frontalier
qui que vous aimez bien on est avec
dites-vous une population passée de
mineur de fond à comptable de fond et ça
ça a l'air de vous gêner euh de vous
poser un petit problème non ça me gêne
pas je je je je je suis ravi que les
gens ne meurent plus de silicose c'est
parce que ceux qui vont travailler au
Luxembourg ils font des sous-métiers
dans les banques luxembourgeoises ils
font ils font c'est une main
d'œuvre ce que raconte Nicolas dans VO
considère cette main
d'œuvre des comptables de fond ce qui
est intéressant c'est que enfin moi ce
qui m'intéressait dans ce dans ce ce
personnage et ce métier c'est que
finalement il en vient à faire une tâche
répétitive sur des tableaux Excel pour
la finance internationale donc au
Luxembourg et toutes les 2 heures il
doit republier le le prix des des des
fonds de pension et des fonds
d'investissement et s'il a pas terminé à
17h de toute façon son enfant il est à
la crèche au rez-de-chaussée qu'il a
levé à 5h de du mat pour faire 1h de0 de
voiture à l'allée 1h de0 de voiture au
retour et finalement pour construire des
maisons qui évidemment sont le signe
d'un accomplissement matériel mais qui
recommence quelque chose de la cité
ouvrière quoi et donc on a
transposé le le les cités
minières dans dans le dans le ce
capitalisme financier au Luxembourg je
suis pas nostalgique de la de la mine
c'est juste que excusez-moi je fini que
sur la question collective ou les les
mineurs de fond avaient une vie
collective et sociale et et et de lutte
qui était animé par un employeur commun
et cetera là dans les maisons
individuelles et dans un monde qui est
de plus en plus individualiste et dont
le collègue de travail est lui aussi
frontalier mais qui vient peut-être de
100 km ailleurs il a il y a plus du tout
ce tissu et et donc ça fabrique
effectivement des gens qui qui ne sont
que tournés sur leur propre famille et
qui en plus effectivement dans une vie
sociale où bah il se retrouve quand même
avec d'autres frontaliers parce que dans
ce lotissement ils sont tous frontaliers
au moins un voire les deux par par foyer
et ils disent que bah évidemment ils
font pas les mêmes voyage ils ont pas
les mêmes bagnoles et cetera et que au
fur et à mesure ben dans leur cercle
d'amis c'est quand même aussi des fond
évidemment c'est pas une généralité mais
ça fabrique effectivement c'est ces ces
vies qui sont un peu plus hors sol et
qui ne sont qui sont pas dans les mêmes
notions de de euh voilà de de de de
lutte sociale que que pouvait l'être les
les mineurs de fond il y a 30 ans mais
c'est pas de la moi j'ai noté aussi un
autre petit paradoxe on l'a vu ce sont
des les conditions matérielles les
conditions salariales sont on ne peut
plus euh plus intéressant au Luxembourg
que que côté français enfin il y a quand
même quelqu'un euh euh qui disait que
euh au Luxembourg les Luxembourgeois euh
utilisent les français pour des métiers
qui qu'ils ne veulent plus faire qu'ils
ne veulent plus faire donc ça on n pas
on n pas trop le regarde comment sont
perçus ses salariés bon on sait que
parfois ils sont pas toujours très bien
perçus effectivement c'est un peu les
les les jobs pas forcément les plus
intéressants et en même temps il y a
cette fierté un moment donné si
quelqu'un le le dit dans le documentaire
les Français ont fait le Luxembourg
finalement cette idée que finalement bah
le Luxembourg bah il doit une partie de
sa richesse et sa prospérité au salariés
frontaliers au salariés français voilà
moi moi j'aimerais alors c'est la ma
petite frustration moi de de politiste
c'est de pas savoir un petit peu ce
qu'il pense politiquement euh c'estes
gens a priori j'ai pas je suis pas sûr
qu'il votent à gauche ou alors peut-être
par ou alors peut-être qu'ils ont une
tension entre leur tradition familiale
bon sachant qu'en plus localement il y a
le lescatie populaire dans ce coin-là ne
vote pas forcément à gauche he au départ
parce qu'il y a une empreinte du
catholicisme social et cetera qui qui
est forte mais ça serait intéressant de
savoir un petit peu quel effet sur leur
Opin l'union politique a eu cet
embourgeoisement le fait de de sortir de
sa classe le fait finalement de de vivre
un petit peu comme ça dans une forme de
confinement social ça ça ça sera
intéressant de voir bah le bureau de
vote là le bureau de vote de
slottissement pour pour pour pour qui il
a voté au dernier au dernières élections
ça pourrait être intéressant ouais en
tout cas moi j'ai quelques chiffres qui
sont ceux des deux dernières
présidentielles c'est Marine Le Pen
arrive assez largement en tête
d'ailleurs que ça soit en Mosel ou en
meurt et Mosel au premier tour à la fois
en 2017 et et 2022 et puis en Mosel
c'est vraiment un score très très serré
au second tour entre Emmanuel Macron et
et et Marine Le Pen ça se joue à à
quelques quelques points ça votit quoi
traditionnellement dans cette région euh
bah c'est c'est euh c'est assez
contrasté en fait hein parce que c'était
une terre évidemment aussi où le
mouvement ouvrier était structuré mais
en même temps une terre aussi où la
droite
catholique s'est implantée donc c'est
pas la Lorine ça n'a jamais été le nordp
de calé en terme de d'ancrage notamment
militant hein voilà donc là bon
globalement on regarde aux élections
législatives bon il y a des il y a des
députés LFI Charlotte le duuc Caroline
Fiat il y a Dominique potier qui est une
figure du du PS qui est un catholique
social on peut le dire et puis il y a
des députés de droite c'est assez euh
voilà c'est c'est c'est pas très très
marqué c'est un peu à l'image de la
France mais je pense aussi que c'est des
départements qui sont très hétérogènes
socialement aussi t tous les territoires
il y a des territoires très différents
il y a aussi des des des des des villes
des villages du front tout le monde pas
frontalier donc il c'est une terre aussi
de contraste social B on va demander
àabelle roche hein quels sont vos
électeurs ceux qui votent Isabelle
roche on trouve de nombreux frontaliers
pour ce que vous en savez j'imagine
qu'il y a quand même quelques études
locales qui vous permettent de vous
situer oui mais alors untit peu le tissu
électoral dans votre région j'ai enfin
une particularité c'est que n'y a pas
que les frontaliers qui votent pour moi
euh puisque j'ai un ancrage local depuis
déjà de nombreuses années avec et si
vous l'avez regardé ma fiche Wikipédia
avec un parcours politique qui fait que
on va dire quel que soit l'étiquette et
quel que soit le territoire par du Parti
socialiste vous concernant ensuite udi
et puis ensuite vous vous rejoignez la
réubl en marche pour finir aujourd'hui à
horizon tout à fait donc je sais pas si
c'est une fin mais bon on verra je pense
que c'est je vous souhaite pas en tout
cas voilà c'est c'est je et vous avez un
discours qui s'adresse à ces frontaliers
travilles frali mais pas que les
frontaliers c'est pour ça ce que j'étais
en train de vous dire euh moi j'ai été
adjointe aux affaires scolaires j'ai été
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
en charge du tourisme et j'ai toujours
été la personne qui fait que quand on
s'adresse à moi s'il y a un problème je
vais faire en sorte de le résoudre et
d'apporter une solution une perspective
et de prendre la réalité du terrain et
la réalité du terrain comme elle est et
pas comme je voudrais qu'elle soit et ça
je pense que c'est aussi une une grosse
différence avec un un certain nombre de
de de personnes des des de on va dire de
candidats aux élections donc euh de
vraiment avoir la réalité du terrain qui
me colle à la peau pour savoir comment
je vais faire chaque jour pour améliorer
leur quotidien et c'est vraiment ce qui
m'anime donc après effectivement il y a
des frontaliers quotidien des
frontaliers vous avez beaucoup travaillé
surou j'ai beaucp bien sûr vu ça mais
tout à fait mais je pour éviter ces
alers-retours j'imagine mais je
travaille beaucoup sur le quotidien des
frontaliers mais je travaille beaucoup
sur le quotidien de mes concitoyens en
règle générale et donc comme je vous
disais il y a des frontaliers qui votent
pour moi il n'y a pas que des
frontaliers heureusement parce que s'il
n'y avait que les frontaliers je ne
serais pas élu est-ce que vos vos
concitoyens sont encore marqué ce qui
pas été ce qui a été l'histoire de de de
cette région après guerre et sa et son
histoire sidérurgique hein j'ai j'ai
juste simplement quelques chiffres qui
remontent à 1974 on aurait pu revenir
bien avant il y a donc 50 ans la
citurgie faisait travailler 78000
salariés pour produire plus de la moitié
de l'aciet français 25 ans plus tard il
nétait plus que 16000 en 2012 on fer met
le le dernier au fourneau oui hein du
côté de de Hayange je crois et de
Florange euh ce traumatisme là
aujourd'hui il est il est vraiment
derrière vos concitoyens ou il est
encore très pesant et et on peut aussi
quelque part le percevoir dans dans ce
film cette fameuse nostalgie dont on
parlait tout à l'heure est-ce qu'elle
est là alors pour certains oui pour
d'autres pas du tout parce que il y a eu
des reconversions sur le territoire on a
des entreprises de pointe je pense par
exemple à tison CRE on a moi sur ma
circo j'ai une une entreprise qui
exporte c'est l'entreprise Semin qui
fait des choses extraordinaire qui
exporte dans dans le monde entier et qui
est une entreprise locale avec des des
personnes qui qui sont là donc qui ont
qui ont un de la Red vraiment très
poussé donc on voit que il y a aussi
parce que il y avait un passé
sidérurgique des entreprises qui sont
venus pour bénéficier de cette expertise
et de cette capacité de cette force de
travail donc qu'il y a une reconversion
qui est qui qui a lieu pour une partie
sur le sol de de la Lorine avec
justement ce ce passé sidérurgique
transformé de compéten et de on a un
labo de recherche l'ircide dans le dans
le domaine des des matériaux des
composantes sidérurgiqu donc on voit que
on a su finalement beaucoup mieux
dépasser j'ai pas dit que ça a été
facile he mais qu'on a réussi à dépasser
trtis l'oire siè encore siè je je je dis
bien on a su dépasser ce traumatisme
mais je pense que la région a su
beaucoup mieux le dépasser mais par
contre n'a pas su le vendre à
l'extérieur on a encore une image de
notre région qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité de ce qui est vécu cette
nostalgie c'était de cette nostalgie là
dont il était question s'il y en avait
hein dans votre film mais euh avant je
continue à à effectivement qu'il puisse
y avoir éventuellement vous l' peut-être
tout simplement mélancolie mais mais euh
je mais je ne mais je vois pas de
nostalgie on n'est pas du tout dans un
cétait mieux avant encore une fois moi
je pense que l'accomplissement je ne
juge absolument pas cet accomplissement
et et je suis très heureux pour pour
tous ces tous ces gens qui qui qui
s'accomplissent ce qui m'intéressait
c'était au contraire de parler de la
question de euh du Luxembourg de cette
en fait finalement le Luxembourg c'est
quand même aussi un laboratoire de
l'Europe c'est-à-dire que euh mê dans
vos interview que ce territoire il a été
tenu à bout de bras à un moment par cet
eldorado que le luembourou bien mais
parce que en fait la la on a on a effacé
les frontières et mais du point de vue
du droit social il continue à y avoir
des des des écarts d'un pays à l'autre
c'est ce qui fabrique des migrations des
travaill ailleurs détaché et sur cette
question là des frontaliers qui sont
encore un autre type de de de
singularité de de du droit social et qui
fabrique des déséquilibres et quand même
encore des des formes de de de
d'asservissement si je peux dire parce
que évidemment les Luxembourg sont pas
toujours t les Luxembourgeois pardon
sont pas toujours tendres avec leurs
employés parce queils savent que
derrière de toute façon il y en a 40 qui
se qui se bousculent pour pour prendre
la place et pour autant toutes ces
personnes que vous avez rencontré vrai
que ça non c'est pas non c'est pas aussi
vrai que ça parce que justement euh le
Luxembourg est confronté aussi à une
pénurie de main d'œuvre et c'est pas
aussi vrai queil y ait 40 personnes au
contraire le et donc on et on les les
frontaliers n'occupent pas que des
emplois euh on va dire peu qualifiés ou
enfin c'est ah non d'ailleurs c'est pas
ce que disent les chiffres sont plutôt
des emplois qualifi du côté du
Luxembourg comme la Suisse d'ailleurs
bien sûr et c'est je c'était c'était
c'était pour ça que je voulais y
insister et le Luxembourg a besoin des
frontaliers et notamment des frontaliers
français qui sont très bien formés
maintenant on voit justement et pourquoi
on gagne des des habitants parce qu'il y
a des gens qui arrivent de Paris d'un
peu partout pour venir bosser à
Luxembourg et souvent vivre en France
parce qu'il y a aussi une qualité de vie
que l'on peut offrir sur le territoire
français donc c'est c'est encore autre
chose et et c'est pour ça que je disais
je pense que vraiment on a on n' pas su
se vendre à l'extérieur sur le fait que
c'est un peu le côté taiseux des des
lorins qui fait que bah voilà on fait
mais on dit pas
et et donc finalement quand on on est
quand on vient faire un documentaire sur
notre territoire ou quand on écrit des
livres qui parlent de notre territoire
bah c'est
toujours avec ce passé qui qui qui nous
colle et pas euh tiré vers vers cet
avenir que tout le monde auquel tout le
monde travaille r le F pour la
conclusion he ça vaêtre la fin de cette
émission la difficulté à gérer le
stigmat d'une région au passé industriel
lourd en fait et tout tout ce que ça
procure à la fois y a ceux qui veulent
dépasser cette cette image là et puis il
y a ce il y a aussi les effets de cette
image donc il faut composer avec ça il y
a le regard du documentariste il y a le
regard de l'élu moi j'ai un regard
plutôt extérieur euh voilà et je je
pense que je pense que ça ne donne pas
toute une image du territoire voilà
c'est là c'était le langue de des
frontaliers voilà donc après après
effectivement quelle image est-ce que ce
territoire se vend mal son image je ne
sais pas mais c'est très difficile aussi
de gérer une image comme ça de
l'extérieur historiquement quand elle
est aussi chargé tout c'est pas
l'ancienne vice-présidente auutorisme
qui va vous dire le contraire par
ailleurs c'est un film où il y a il y a
pas de fourneau hein c'est vous qui
voyez encore ses stigmat mais nous on
les a pas montréin et puis quoi qu'il en
soit tous ceux que vous avez vu dans ce
film vivent en France hein il y en a
aucun qui a souhaité aller vivre au
Luxembourg pas les moyens pour le coup
he il y a quand même vraiment cette
problématique c'est qu'au Luxembourg le
prix de l'immobil est
tellement élevé que il préfère aller de
l'autre côté de la frontière ce qui fait
encore une fois monter les prix on a
évoqué la question de l'immobilier
évidemment cette fois ça sera vraiment
le mot de la fin merci un grand merci à
tous les trois spécialement à vous et
votre compère qui avait réalisé tous les
deux ce ce film Il était une fois dans
l'Est qui a constitué la base de de ce
débat doc vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadoc j'espère qu'elles ne
sonont pas uniquement Lorine ces
réactions et puis je vous fais confiance
pour réagir à ce que sont ces réactions
tout particulièrement vous Isabelle
roche évidemment on parle d'une région
vous connaissez tellement bien merci à
Selma sali également qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission rendez-vous pour
un prochain lesbadoc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt